- I like a man who knows their water.
- (laughs)
(Latino music)
- When you see those bottles
that cost like $6.00 for water,
I'm insulted.
- I bought a water on an
airplane once, it was $10.00.
- I wanna be beautiful after this.
(Latino music)
- Have you ever been to Beverly Hills?
- I don't think I'm allowed there.
This bottle is really pretty though.
- It's probably LA tap water
that they just bottled.
- Is Beverly Hills a
place known for water?
Like, I don't think it is.
- [Man] Cheers
- [Woman] Cheers
- It's really, really
clean and I feel like
it has no after taste.
- Yeah, it tastes like
water, tastes like tap water.
- This tastes like I'm drinking nothing.
- It'll get the job done,
but I'm not gonna pay
more than $1.00 for it.
(Latino music)
- From Wales.
- We're gettin' international up in here.
- It's crazy to think that they
like ship water, over water.
- Hmm
- It's a little bit more full.
I'm making this shit
up, but it kinda fits.
- That one has a bite.
- [Woman] It's crisper.
- [Man] This is crisper.
- I mean, I just taste, water.
- Or like after a marathon,
this would like really hydrate you.
- [Woman] Fiuggi
- [Man] Oh lord.
- [ Woman] It's mineral water, natural
mineral water. - [Man] Rome, Rome.
- Damn, look at that!
There's like 20 ingredients in this thing.
- This is not just water,
this is healthy water.
- I like this, I like this water.
- It tastes like chalky in my mouth.
- This is like my tap water.
- I mean, you have great tap water then.
- I'm definitely tasting
some, like elements.
- It's got a bad, like after
taste in the back of my mouth.
- Maybe this is just like ancient water,
cause it tastes kinda old
- [Man] Yeah, out of the aqueducts.
(Latino music)
- What is this?
- I mean, it's something that I would love
to have in a fight.
- Also, can you carry
it, like out in public?
But like, the cops pull you over,
sorry, I'm just drinking water.
- It has a cork! Why does
the cork have a condom on it?
- This is the dumbest thing
I've even done in my life.
- Same water, it's all the same.
I can't deal with this.
- Tastes like tap water.
- I think the coating of the bottle
might affect the taste.
- Yeah, this is gross.
- The water was nasty, I
need you all to know that.
- Actually it's pretty good.
- I think this is the only
one that actually has,
like some flavor to it.
- I think I would rather just keep it
to ward off evil spirits.
- Yeah, it's kinda bull shit.
- I feel like all these expensive waters,
is literally just the bottle.
- I'm disappointed in
expensive water companies.
It just tastes like regular ass water.
- [Woman] Drink lots of water
kids, it makes you grow fast.
- [Man] And pee a lot.
- This is a disgrace
to humanity right here.
- My throat is dry.